after nine rounds over seven days the
2013 classic has come to an end and the
winners have been decided John
Bartholomew had an amazing tournament in
the final he drew panjwani in just 10
minutes to clinch 1st place in the GM
field that draw brought him to the magic
six and a half points and I knew pretty
much after I won against by arena in
round 6 to set myself up on five out of
six points that I was in a really
favorable spot in that you know drawers
were looking good for me down the
stretch especially with two whites like
I was feeling good but um I was ready to
fight in any game if necessary koroche
was kind of a question mark because I
wasn't sure he's a very tricky player
once I got by with the draw against him
in around seven pretty much felt that
the norm was within reach I mean there's
a lot of leeway just not needing to win
in the final rounds when a draw is
acceptable so psychology wise I think
now that I'm a little older and more
mature like I could see my younger self
maybe like panicking in a situation like
this and possibly even doing something
how to be ordinary but I just played the
chest that I've been playing I stuck
with my same opening losses white like D
401 and I felt very confident throughout
the event even in the last few rounds
even though they weren't exciting at all
so this is my final round game against
Raja panjwani and obviously half point
would secure me the norm so I'm going to
be playing this pretty close to the vest
I play d4 just as I had done throughout
the tournament and he responded with the
Dutch which boorish had also played
against me couple rounds prior and I
played G 39 f6 Bishop g2 e6 portals
played this a little bit differently he
chose a set up with g6 Bishop g7 which
is a bit more combative Rogers going for
the stone wall which is a really solid
line I played c4 played c69 f.3d five
castles and then Bishop d6 and it's
pretty well known that one of the best
plans for weight is to try to eliminate
the dark square Bishop
in this position so I played b3
contending Bishop e3 pretty standard he
went Queenie 7 and i played Bishop b2
and then Raja castle and again white can
really seek to exchange the dark squared
bishop here by playing this plan with
Queen c1 and Bishop a3 which kills a lot
of the dynamic play in the position
which of course suits me just fine given
my tournament position I played night
bd2 in this position in the past
actually pretty recently in a couple
games but I think under the
circumstances Queen see one makes a lot
of sense and then Bishop d7 Bishop a3
bishop I ate we trade on d6 I played
Queen a three and then take and take and
here I offer to draw which he accepted
and guaranteed me the norm kind of my
last three games followed the same
pattern that I offer to draw right when
the hostilities could start but all in
positions where I felt like pretty
comfortable so I'm just very happy to
have made this person or and this is the
best tournament I've ever had by far
I've achieved my first GM norm feels
great especially to do it here in st.
Louis at a very fantastic we organized
event I really got to hand it to guys
this was a great event one of the best
i've ever played in i honestly don't
know what's next for me i hope to
continue playing and this might adjust
my plans a little bit i mean any time
you feel like you're in good form you
want to try to build on that and make
make other things happen so i think i'm
going to try to look at the next few
months and see if there's a couple
tempting events i can play to maybe get
another GM norm opportunity or to
Bartholomew has earned his first Grand
Master norm this is also the first norm
of any kind earned at the Chess Club in
two years two more performances like
this and he will be a grandmaster in the
second section Sean Vivat had his back
against the wall he had to win against
Andrew gore vets to achieve his second
international master norm unfortunately
for Shawn Gore of it stifled the hope of
the ambitious seventeen-year-old I know
it was very hard for me make the
comeback the five rounds I mean I almost
did
next what I would hope for for this I
almost went through one all six but I'm
okay with it I made a blunder in the
last round it's not too bad but still I
had a half out of three and now I ended
up winning five on the rest of the six
I'm pretty happy he played fantastic
this tournament the game he played
against me i had made tons of threats
and attacks against him and every single
one he seemed play almost the perfect
move i looked at the game afterwards at
the engine it's like move after move
after move here's him making the perfect
so he definitely deserved the win with
his win I am Corvettes claimed victory
in the IM norm field and walks away with
first place also notable this round
priyadarshan and Irina Krush battled to
a 110 move draw that made everyone late
for dinner it was crushes chance to nab
an extra three hundred dollars but Irina
couldn't get pre to crack with each
strong closed event it holds the chess
club and scholastic center of st. Louis
increases its prominence in the
international arena we'll see you at the
next st. Louis classic